hey guys it's Justine and today we're
going to be doing an iPhone accessory
video I've been wanting to do this video
for a while so when I decided to finally
shoot this I went through and thought of
all the things that I've been using most
frequently with my iPhone some of the
things are pretty common like obviously
an iPhone charging case but some are not
so common like another massive satellite
phone I've been such a huge fan of
Mophie for so long and a huge thank you
to them for sponsoring this video check
out the link in the description or check
out Mophie commerce stuff I want to talk
about mo fees iPhone charging case this
is their new one the juice pack access
what I love so much about this case is
you can charge it wirelessly or you can
also charge it with a USB cable and this
will pass through and also charge your
iPhone and you still have access to the
Lightning port which means you can be
charging and still use other accessories
at the same time it's also a pretty slim
case as you can see I'm such a huge fan
of wireless charging I also hate
carrying multiple cables so to be able
to charge my phone not only wirelessly
but also by using USB C is such great
news there's also a power button on the
back so you can turn the case on or off
and you can also see what your charge is
at and I also have something else to go
along with this this has been one of my
favorite charging stands this thing has
been around the country with me I
haven't been traveling international
much lately but this is what I now
travel with so I don't have to ever
bring any cords or cables this is also
by Mophie this charge is not only your
Apple watch but it'll charge your air
pods and your phone at the same time or
anything else that's Qi wireless
compatible you can also charge it here
you might notice that this is the size
of another accessory that we're gonna be
talking about here shortly I cannot
stress enough how amazing this is so
these are my old air pods case that
actually happened to be in
a little nomads leather skin this thing
is amazing so I can charge my ear pods
my Apple watch and my phone and my
charging case all in one but this thing
has been so great
it'll also charge the new air pause well
it doesn't have a snug of a fit as the
old ones it still charges it while we're
talking about movie products ok so I've
kind of sort of destroyed this one
because it has been travelling with me
everywhere as well in my gear bag this
is a little AC adapter but what's great
about this is it gives you two USB ports
and also a USB C port and this itself is
a charger it also charges wirelessly so
you can set your phone directly on top
of it and my phone's charging right now
I like this a lot too because this does
give me three of a USB ports so when I
am traveling this also acts as a little
USB hub so this I don't leave home
without I was mentioning this case so
it's like a little leather case that
goes over top of your ear pods this is
made I know that
and it's really cool it also comes in a
brown leather as well but I like how
well it matches all of my accessories
I'm gonna put my watch back on now
because I'm missing out on all this
activity all this moving around come on
I should I should sort of work out
obviously another accessory are the new
air Potts Pro I've been using these a
lot I still travel with both my old air
pods and my new air pods just mostly
because I'm afraid that I'm gonna lose
one of them and I need to have a backup
because I'm always editing so if I don't
have some sort of headphones I'm gonna
be in trouble next up this is a weird
accessory but I felt bad that my phone
would always see me on my macbook so I
didn't want it to feel bad anymore so I
got it its own MacBook I think Siri do
you like the MacBook that I got you you
know what they say baby got Mac I think
that's how it goes anyway this is just a
little silly mirror that I found I don't
actually use this on a daily basis oh
gosh maybe I should I thought it was
cute I just found it in my drawer next
up I showed you guys this in the
beginning but this is a Garmin satellite
phone and you might be wondering how
this is an accessory to my iPhone when I
am hiking or out in places without
reception this connects to satellites in
the sky Thank You Garmin and there's
also an app on my phone so I can use the
satellite phone to text and communicate
with people even if I don't have cell
reception this also has an SOS button so
this can alert authorities or rescue
people hopefully nearby to come save me
somewhere and I'll also text message a
bunch of my emergency contacts in here
so I don't really ever leave home
without this I actually almost did have
to use this
when my friends and I were in Montana
this woman fell like off this cliff and
there was no cell reception where she in
falafels but it wasn't like that far but
it was still like a little ledge and she
was bleeding and she did not seem well
so Tyler's back there he was there to
witness all of that it was really scary
and I had my phone
I was ready thankfully she was okay and
they had some people there on hand that
worked in the park and they were able to
bus her and get her the help that she
needed I definitely recommend if you're
an avid hiker or somebody who does do a
lot of outdoor activities where there is
no cell reception I love it next up this
is I can't even call it an iPhone
accessory but it's sort of visit
accessory it's basically its own
standalone camera but it works really
well with your iPhone so this is a
little tiny Steadicam you guys have seen
the review of the awesomo mobile before
I've also done Beto give us on this
little guy they also have an entire line
of drones which I see me review but this
little thing is so great because it's so
small you can get some shots that you
never could get before because you just
plug it right in and you can see
everything that you're filming right on
the front of your iPhone you can also
edit videos in the app you can shoot
really cool time lapses it's just really
awesome if used you travel a lot it's
probably one of my favorite iPhone
accessories it's not actually an iPhone
accessory you know what I mean look how
steady Wow there was an earthquake right
now we'd be ready
actually what me ready is I think a lot
of my emergency supplies has expired
next up a mobile tripod from jovi now
this isn't the version that I wanted to
show you because I lost the version but
it's just so cute but I will show you
what I wanted to show you that I can't
show you because I don't have it anymore
this is a little tripod mount and this
can open to various sizes depending upon
your phone size the one that I lost had
extra places that you could mount these
extra arms on to and it was awesome
because you could put a light you could
put a microphone or I don't even know
like another phone on top of it but I
lost it and I don't know where it is and
I think about her a lot
you want to hear another funny story
anybody that cares to listen so I have a
problem when I buy things online
I don't ever look at the actual
measurements I just look at the picture
and then I is some crazy I just seen
fashion I formulate in my mind besides
that I think that is and I think that's
going to show up so I once ordered
basically a tripod this size when I
opened up that Amazon box I about lost
my mind because I was like what am I
ever supposed to do with this but it's
so cute that I just can't bring myself
to ever I don't know I just couldn't
return it because it it just it's like a
baby
this is a little iPhone microphone so it
used to vlog a lot more than I do now so
being able to have better audio on your
iPhone it's really great so you can just
plug this in just like so
and guess what it works so if I'm
vlogging this way
I wish that it would be able to swing
all the way around but it doesn't that's
they really missed the boat on that one
so you can also just unplug it that way
just a little light right there so you
can see if it's working this is a video
test of not having a microphone on it
Wow
this Mac looks so good back there and
this front-facing camera here's a test
using the microphone and do I need to
reiterate how great this new Mac Pro
looks back there oh my goodness these
lights - oh man so this is a great
little microphone especially if you're
in windy situations this little added
wind ball it's a real Saviour all right
I think we have a few more things this
is a stand this is not a thousand dollar
stand just much like our Mac Pro display
XD ours but really there's nothing that
special about the stand but I do love
always having a little stand to put
either my phone or my iPad on feel like
this stand particularly is way better
for an iPad because it's really big but
you can put your phone in I also used to
use this to house a picture of my dog
did I print it out so really hits
multiple uses why I'm mentioning this
Dan I'm not sure it was an accessory
that I used quite often so I just wanted
to tell you guys about it last but not
least this is a little light from a
pitcher that I've been using for the
past few years this is so small so tiny
and it's powered by USB which is great
because if you're traveling the last
thing that you want to do is be lugging
around external batteries because then
you have to charge the batteries so
anything that can be charged through usb
on the fan of and this thing is
extremely bright it's got some buttons
here on the side so you can change the
brightness is it changing one's videos
that I remember us using this we already
three do you member we were on Luigi's
Mansion yes and we use this it was
pretty dark in there so this actually
did a really great job there's a new
version of this if it does RGB colors
that Tyler has and he was showing me how
cool it is because it connects to an
iPhone app so you can do all sorts of
fun little things which model is this
one cool little like plastic softbox
so there it is I've got a little on
button here it also have a little
display that will show you the different
color temperatures it also has like an
effects mode here's the effects this is
the fire of that
Oh cup car oh wow I'm shocked this is
the party mode there's some Lightning oh
wow this is cool cuz you can again hook
this up to your iPhones you even have
access to all of these you can set
different modes and if you have
multiples of these you can sync them all
together and have a real freakin party I
got to get this but it's backordered
right now also nice because it's charges
with USB see thank you again this is I
think they're going for like less than
fifty dollars right now and this one's
like one hundred beauty so the one that
I ordered that I thought was this one is
actually an upgraded version of this one
it's just a bicolor I was looking for
something that was a little bit bigger
than this one so that I'd be able to
have a little more light when I'm
traveling and I also wanted it to be a
USB charge so I guess I'll open this
this is like a little surprise to me
okay
do you know where one is
[Laughter]
smooth possible night man apertures
pretty great we also got this other
lights that we're using right now not an
iPhone accessory but I'm into it oh look
anything look cliff I love how flat and
thin this case is put only things in
there we've got some little 3m stickies
it looks like we have a little bit
fusion paper there wait a minute I
thought it was gonna be bigger this has
so many more LED lights on it it also
kind of has like this little heatsink
here on the back Wow well this is good
because now I can travel with both of
them in the same case I like that it
changes color temperature colder warmer
oh this a little booster - that will
probably definitely kill through the
battery but if you need a little extra
light
also a USBC port here to charge and I'm
so excited that this is us BC because
most of the movie charging tricks are
all now us BC so if I need some extra
battery I can just plug that directly
into one of these low fees what I'm
traveling this is such a savior right so
I fit both of my lights in here this is
such a great travel option whether
you're using your phone whether you're
vlogging on bigger cameras like this
both of these lighting options are
amazing I think that I wanted to show
you guys today well that's it I hope you
guys enjoyed some of these accessories
that I've been using for my iPhone I'd
love to hear from you guys what have you
been using and if there's anything you'd
like or you think that I should try out
leave those in the comments below and
also feel free to send me a tweet again
thank you to Mophie for sponsoring this
video and you guys are the best if you
guys want to check out anything will be
related it check out the link in the
description and with that I will see you
guys later
[Music]